[Music]
on this saturday night
bc burning with no end in sight
with dozens of new wildfires what we're
learning about how an entire town was
destroyed
it wasn't like it went home to home it
was everywhere
multiple out-of-control fires in
northern california
how the state's fire crews are dealing
with a year-round wildfire season
and why the remains of the collapsed
condo in florida
are set to come down
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us there is
little relief in british columbia where
more fires have erupted after a week of
unprecedented heat there are more than
170 fires burning across the province
right now
76 of them ignited in just the last two
days
nine are considered wildfires of note
burning more than
63 000 hectares combined that's more
than
600 square kilometers according to the
bc wildfire service
lightning is suspected to have caused 68
percent of the active fires the
devastated community of litton is still
closed off to residents leaving families
anxiously awaiting news about their
missing loved ones
global's paul haysom is on the outskirts
of litton where
a search for victims could begin soon
paul
the colleen forensics teams have arrived
to enter that community today and to
begin the
heartbreaking task of searching for
victims from a fire
that ravaged this community it has been
just too dangerous
too toxic for anyone to enter the
village of litton
until now at least two people are known
to have died but there are several more
people still
unaccounted for residents had mere
moments to escape the village's mayor
and evacuee himself
tells global news it was just 15 minutes
from the moment he first smelled the
smoke
until he watched fire incinerate his
community
it was stunning how quick
you know we had gone from no fires to
just fully engulfed it wasn't like it
went home to home
it was everywhere it brings tears to the
bags
um you know also the
conserve for the people that were in
those buildings
and you know the fact that we don't know
if they all got out alive
that's very very hard to
to um you know to
to take the linton fire is still growing
north of the community residents of
another 100 homes have been forced to
evacuate
evacuation orders are in effect in other
parts of the province as well
an out-of-control fire south of kamloops
has grown to 31 thousand hectares
also threatening homes the ski chest and
indian band issued an evacuation order
for two reserves on friday night
and nearly 700 properties remain under
evacuation order around
deca lake near the community of 100 mile
house the district fire chief says
around 100 firefighters from other parts
of the province
are expected to lend a hand as the
situation gets worse
there's a number of fires around us
around the district 100 mile
so we can they can go to any any of
these fires and be able to protect the
homes
for the citizens out there and mother
nature is not helping the combination of
heat
wind and now lightning are expected over
the next week
serving as a triple threat right across
the province
colleen paul haysom thank you paul
in alberta an investigation is underway
into a deadly house fire that erupted
early friday morning in chestermere just
east of calgary
seven people including four children
were killed as matthew conrod reports
the community is shattered
one day after a house fire in
chestermare took the lives of seven
people
including four children ranging in age
from four to twelve
neighbors and community members are
still trying to come to terms with the
immense and tragic loss
i was just out for an early ride
yesterday morning and accidentally came
upon it and
it was shocked and horrified it hit
everybody hard
it's you know everybody has kids and
it's very sad
amjad kamal his wife batul and their
five children had only recently moved
into their home in chestermir after
arriving in alberta from ontario
according to community members
on thursday he welcomed his brother
assad and his wife rafia and their three
children over for a canada day
celebration
rcmp say it was just after 2 30 in the
morning on friday that a fire broke out
i'm just got out of the house somehow he
saved four kids
two affairs and two of his brothers
assad's but he couldn't
the assad his wife and his own wife
and four other kids they couldn't make
it suddenly
four seven people were swiped off this
world
and on earth and just left us so
i still i can't believe that two
fundraisers have been set up for the
families and a vigil is being planned in
chestermir on monday at 8 pm
for now residents say this is when the
community will need to show its strength
we're all in the same boat together you
know and it wouldn't matter if it
happened to my neighbor or someone down
the street
if they need something people should be
willing to help what they can
rcmp say the cause of the fire is still
under investigation
matthew conrad of global news
it has been 10 days since that deadly
building collapse in florida
24 people are confirmed dead but 121 are
still unaccounted for
including four canadians as reggie
jacini reports
the search is once again being paused as
officials prepare to demolish what
remains of the tower
it serves as a reminder of the pain and
suffering felt by a shattered community
and for many families a planned
demolition of the remaining part of the
champlain tower
might lend to a sense of closure you'd
hate to see there'd be another disaster
out there with this building being if it
falls in the wrong way
it's not structurally sound and the
threat of tropical weather expedited
engineering studies
ensuring a quick removal i mean 40 to 50
mile an hour winds
could have a major impact on
on the existing debris falling it's
it's a it's a real danger but it's a
devastating blow for those
still holding out hope for a miracle
rescue an
already painstakingly slow search will
now be paused again
search and rescue does does have to
pause
temporarily while the demolition
preparation is underway
so preparation includes activities like
drilling
into columns there is threat to the
standing building that is posed to the
first responders
it's another delay to getting answers
and holding someone accountable
there were dire warnings about the
building's integrity and new reports
suggest the condos board had been
pleading with the city for construction
permits
up until just hours before the tower
fell being right by the ocean
and the salt water there are impacts on
the concrete
and the steel structures within the
concrete the champlain towers fate
only adds fuel to a structural audit of
buildings from the 70s and 80s when
underground parking
and balconies became key features
there's coral and limestone beneath the
surface it's not the soundest of
foundations to build on building codes
changed in 1992
following hurricane andrew after the
surfside building was built
and hundreds of others like this one in
north miami beach
which was evacuated on friday i think
the building is not having some
permits and they need to bring their
engineer
to check the building if there is
detection there should be an inspection
and layered on top of the county-wide
audits and investigations a federal
probe requested by the president by the
agency that looked into the world trade
center collapse
an initial assessment was started on
friday by the national institute of
standards and technology
and while it could take more than a year
to get a full report information could
start being made public in the coming
months colleen
reggie jacini thank you in japan at
least 19 people are missing after a
powerful mudslide hit a town southwest
of tokyo
helpless neighbors watched in horror as
dozens of buildings and vehicles were
swept away
heavy equipment has been brought in to
help with rescue efforts
officials say some people did manage to
leave the area just before the slide
happened
the region has been hit hard by days of
torrential rain
advocates and experts have long been
calling for an
independent reporting structure for
misconduct issues in the canadian
military
this week our american neighbors took a
step towards that goal
the canadian forces have long been under
a renewed spotlight for all kinds of
misconduct issues
but the prime minister won't commit to a
timeline for similar action
abigail beeman has more i have
confidence in the acting chief of staff
i know chief of defense staff the prime
minister was clear he stands behind
lieutenant general wayne ayer after
ayer decided to let the head of the navy
keep his job despite golfing with former
chief of the defense staff jonathan
vance who is under military police
investigation
but justin trudeau was non-committal on
a timeline for a major shift in military
investigations advocates have long been
calling for an external reporting system
outside the chain of command instead
trudeau pointed to the work of former
supreme court justice louis arbor
appointed to lead an external review
into the misconduct that's been plaguing
the forces
and i both absolutely agree that we
can't wait
a year for that final report and that's
why she will be
offering up suggestions and
recommendations
as we move forward as soon as they come
forward
the united states has been grappling
with similar issues as one senior
enlisted officer told us in our
listening sessions
zero tolerance actually means 100
percent tolerance
friday the defense secretary announced a
number of reforms including
removing the prosecution of sexual
assaults and related crimes from the
military chain of command
he's calling for an implementation
roadmap within 60 days the president
stands behind the plan
he views sexual assault as an abuse of
power and affront our shared humanity
and sexual assault in the military is
doubly damaging
though it could take until 2023 to
implement and doesn't go as far as
legislation led by senator
kirsten gillibrand whose bill calls for
broader military justice reforms
still a road map within 60 days which
our prime minister did not commit to
matching
i think there is a contrast uh between
what's going on be
in the united states and and in canada
where we have a secretary of defense
that is way
more proactive than the minister of
national defense
in terms of addressing sexual misconduct
there are of course differences between
the u.s and canadian systems not least
among them the possibility of a fall
election for us here north of the border
giving that idea of
60 days more relevance colleen
abigail beeman in ottawa abigail thank
you
coming up how california crews are
dealing with a year-round wildfire
season
and why fear of the deep isn't the only
obstacle this group of
open water swimmers in bc is overcoming
[Music]
fire crews in northern california are
battling three out of control wildfires
this is a time lapse of what's known as
the salt fire north of reading
it erupted on thursday and has grown
since scorching more than
3 000 hectares several homes and
buildings in the community of lakehead
have been destroyed
investigators believe the fire may have
been caused by a vehicle
saying a hot car part or other hot
material became separated from a vehicle
igniting dry vegetation california has
seen
more than its fair share of devastating
fires in recent years
with climate change driving up
temperatures and increasing drought
conditions
the wildfire season there is virtually
year-round
the state's firefighting agency cal fire
is always on high alert rob malcolm
looks at some of the preparations crews
are taking as they brace for
more fires to come
grass fires along california freeways
tell many here
what they already know fire season has
arrived
the season used to be predictable but
with changing weather patterns
it's not anymore it's hard to say that
we really have a fire season anymore we
basically have a fire year
and the ability to have fires at least
somewhere in the state
any day of the year 2020 marked a record
year for fires in the state
the numbers according to captain
foxworthy were staggering
last year in 2020 the state burned just
shy of 4.3 million acres
in totality in california it was a new
milestone at nearly 1.7 million hectares
encompassing an area larger than the
state of connecticut
and doubling the previous state record
for the most land burned
in a single year obviously the fires are
getting more intense they're burning
later in the year
so obviously it does raise some concern
for the fact that we continue to get
these large damaging fires
for years california prisoners have
played a key role in fighting fires
but due to the pandemic many with less
serious offenses like drug possession
were released early forcing fire
departments to get creative in both
manpower
and machinery we have all our
helicopters fully staffed this year
earlier than we have years in the past
so we're ready for the fire season we
hired an additional roughly 1400
firefighters
here we go new helicopters purchased by
the state
have become another weapon in the fight
these helicopters fly
faster carry more water and have the
ability to work longer
the biggest one that's going to make a
huge difference would be our helicopters
this year
basically it's like a civilian version
of the military blackhawk
the c-130 air tanker will also join
choppers in the air
mere meters from folsom lake where cal
fire continued training
it was apparent why they were getting
prepared as you can see
in the picture behind me we are in
pretty severe drought conditions through
a large swath of california and as a
record heat wave continues to blanket
the pacific northwest
fire crews remain on alert all across
the region
as hot temperatures spark fires a
wildfire in california is no different
than a wildfire
in oregon washington or even canada
they're all the same they all burn the
same
rob malcolm global news sacramento
still ahead the deep sea solution to an
electric vehicle supply problem
and the risks that could surface
the heat waves and wildfires that have
dominated canada summer so far are clear
examples of the global climate crisis
a recent survey found that more than 90
percent of canadians agree
electrification is key to climate action
sales of electric vehicles have surged
in recent years but
finding the metals to make all those
batteries is a challenge in itself
chris galas looks into one possible
solution and the risks involved
deep beneath the ocean surface the
metals company is hoping to help meet
the demand
for electric vehicle batteries
they're after poly metallic nodules
millions of little potato-shaped rocks
lying on the seabed people describe them
as an electric
vehicle battery in a rock because
everything you need to build a battery
cathode
is contained in these nodules high
concentrations of cobalt
nickel copper and manganese the nodules
are found in the clarion clipperton zone
a vast expanse of the south pacific 4
000 meters below the surface there's
something that they start on
could be a shark tooth quite often
or a little piece of shell or something
and the metal that is in solution
in the sea water slowly accretes to the
nodule so
it grows like a pearl over time atom by
atom
the metals company and about a dozen
other international players including
china and russia
have permission from the united nations
international seabed authority to
research
the unique ecosystem down there
[Music]
and they're testing new technology to
suck up the sunken treasure
with the lowest possible impact but some
say the nodules should stay right where
they are
undisturbed given we're in such a grave
situation with the climate emergency
we need to be really careful about
disturbing any kind of processes
that are storing and scavenging carbon
and helping to reduce
that threat of climate change the metals
company argues the risk to the planet is
far
greater if this new source of battery
making material
is not brought to the surface the
environmental and human
costs of land-based mining are well
documented
child laborers have died mining cobalt
in the congo
and recycling alone won't meet demand we
just don't have enough
today that we need to populate the
system and then close the loop
i think probably within 40 or
50 years or so there'll be enough metal
then
that we can keep using it over and over
again
the metals company is planning to go
public later this summer to help fund
its continuing research
and if approved its deep sea mining
operation
chris galas global news
next the group of bc swimmers with a
passion beyond the pool
[Applause]
nothing quite like playing on home ice
in front of fired up fans last night
more than 3
000 supporters packed montreal's bell
center cheering on the canadiens in the
team's first
home game in the stanley cup finals
series since 1993.
despite the energy the habs went down
6-3 to tampa bay
montreal is now just one loss away from
being swept by the lightning
open water swimming is not for the faint
of heart
and that's what makes it so empowering
for the spirit orcas
the victoria bc swimming group is
training to take on some major
challenges
but as jay durant explains these
athletes have
more in common than nerves of steel and
a passion for the pacific
this is the worst part what's the worst
part
maybe it's the cold 10 degree water or
perhaps the strong currents
or it could be the seaweed obstacle
course
none of this has slowed down the spirit
orcas so it's all about
myth busting susan simmons challenged
her group of eight swimmers
and they have all succeeded while facing
their own challenges
think about autism things on the autism
spectrum
learning delay learning disabilities
ptsd these are not
short swims a number of different stages
up to 20 kilometers a day
all part of a planned route across some
vast stretches of open water around bc
for this year i'm doing a very tough
swim from jordan to
colwood the most favorite thing i've
done throughout the year is uh
the great bear swim
oh my legs it's obviously physically
demanding
i'm not doing very well am i but
managing their own varying levels of
anxiety
has been the hardest part okay let's
keep going
all right let's do it building up the
nerve to take the plunge
i'm the king of the ocean and finding
the courage to do it amongst ocean life
you're swimming in waterways with orcas
humpbacks
uh all kinds of wonderful creatures of
the sea that most of us would go oh no i
can't
that's too scary
next summer they'll swim the strait of
juan de fuca three years from now
they're hoping to cross the english
channel
each stroke taking them further away
from that time when this might have
seemed impossible
i'm doing more than what i thought i
could do pretty proud of myself actually
[Music]
jay durant global news
good for them to the atlantic coast now
where one seal
was caught trying some open land
waddling at a popular park have a look
this isn't the usual wildlife you would
see in dartmouth's
shoeby park halifax police received an
early tip about a huge seal in an
off-leash area it took more than six
hours and
five different local and federal
organizations to return the 600 pound
visitor
to the ocean that is global national for
this saturday night i'm colleen christie
for most of canada it's been hot out
there and for wildlife
too cal moo swimming in our cab right in
front of our cabin
this cow moose was captured on camera
taking a dip to escape the heat wave
hitting bc's caribou region
only in canada
you